any surprises for you
yeah well maybe some names who thought
they might be out of contention a few
weeks ago because Gareth Southgate has
brought players back who haven't been
playing for England for some time so
you've got the Manchester United Striker
Marcus rashford he's back in for the
first time since playing his last game
for England in the Euros Final in 2021
of course the game they lost on
penalties to Italy two players have come
back into the England squad for the
first time since
2019. you've got James Madison who's
been so impressive for Leicester
recently that his inclusion made his
case to actually come back into the fold
and that really is seeing Gareth
Southgate being a lot more daring with
this the fact he's also brought Conor
Gallagher in the Chelsea player who's
also barely featured for England so this
is the moment Gareth Southgate knows he
has to deliver after reaching the
semi-finals of the World Cup in 2018 the
final of the Euros in 21 he's been in
the job six years longer than most of
his predecessors so this is the score
God he hopes can deliver at a tournament
like no other we're not heading to the
World Cup like normal in June and July
this is a winter World Cup starting as
you say in barely over a week in
November into December Gareth Southgate
will be hoping to reach that final on
December the 18th in Qatar and giving
them their first World Cup since 1966
but he's got an anxious few days ahead
because there's still one more round of
Premier League games to go given this uh
this date of the World Cup before they
do fly out early next week after
Gathering here at St George's Park